good morning
okay these will get shorter and shorter
as we get close to the end
we're still making very good progress we
have no reason to believe that we won't
complete our count by tomorrow evening
at some point yesterday we had 549
ballots go in
that represented cures and the id
required
we expect to have a small number of
those today as well
again the deadline for the cure is
tomorrow at 5 pm
at which time we'll be able to move all
of those ballots that are eligible to be
counted forward
and get into the system the provisional
update
we are making again very good progress
in the process on our end
as far as determining which of those are
eligible to count the secretary of state
has sent us reports and continues to
send them
we are those are in review and again we
will
we don't anticipate having any issue
rolling those into the system tomorrow
so
in tomorrow's press conference we will
give you information as to when
we expect to report those i don't know
if we're going to go late into the
evening or not if not there's a
possibility we might do it late tomorrow
evening otherwise
it will probably be friday morning at 10
at this final press conference
u.s mail yesterday was the last day
however it is worth mentioning that 15
federal ballots did come in late in the
day yesterday that were eligible to
count and they were processed
questions
the conversation uh continues to be
about these uh
allegations of nefarious activities
still to this point
has anything changed on that end from
your perspective
nothing changed as far as what we're
doing to address them we are still
working with the secretary of state the
items that we've send in
are still consistent uh there has not
been an allegation that we weren't able
to in one way or another explain
or give a scenario as to why or if it
occurred
we'll continue to look as long as those
that information comes in we'll provide
it
yes can you just explain the process by
which
the sos office determines which
provisional ballots
are are good to count conveys that to
your office to spend
chunks when they report how does that
all work
the office of the secretary of state
takes information from all counties and
compares them to make sure that we're
not allowing any duplicate votes from
county to county
we're not the only ones continuing to
process washoe also has work to be done
so it does come in small chunks
the first one being the largest and then
after that it's just follow-up because
we continue to get ballots that cure
and so we need to report that they need
to do a quick check
that'll be continue to happen tomorrow
and at five o'clock it all closes down
and we'll know exactly what needs to be
counted and as you get these
reports do you automatically count those
and put them into the system
to be released say no this morning or
all one time
all at one time tomorrow we'll start
rolling them in
we don't expect to have numbers tomorrow
well today was a small small kick up it
was 549 so
somewhere in those areas i can't tell
you exactly how many but we do continue
to cure so
those ballots will continue to go in so
tomorrow i'll have a report it'll
probably be another small increase
and then there will be a big jump in the
early voting and election day numbers as
the provisional ballots
roll in no later than friday at our 10
o'clock press conference which will be
our last
related to what we've been doing over
the past several days
and then we'll go about finishing up our
reconciling so that we can take care of
the canvas on monday
yes i know that of course as you said
recount cannot be
processed or accepted until after
canvassing on monday but if one were to
come down
what would that process look like that
would process
the nevada state law requires us to
count those ballots exactly how we did
on election night and throughout this
period so
it would look like us in the tabulation
room reading through all of the mail
ballots again
reading all of the cartridges from early
voting on election day it would be done
identically to what we've
done on election night and since then
just to lighten the mood a little bit as
we're coming to the end here um
lightening the mood i like that yes it's
been stressful
um it's a lot of work to get this
accomplished
and you read had a cheeseburger to
celebrate the the super bowl
what are you going to do once canvas is
complete what is going to be the thing
that makes you relax when this is all
over
i i think sleep will be number one
yeah it has been a very stressful
election and my and my staff has done a
tremendous job of hanging on and as i
mentioned the other day they did seem to
get a pep in their step
um because they knew we were close to
the end unfortunately our job
doesn't end we've got two initiative
petitions that are coming in next week
that we
are statutorily required to to work
we're really hoping that we can manage
it so that our staff does get their
thanksgiving with families
and of course if there's a recount then
we're required to get that started
within five days of the request and we
have to finish in five days so that
would be a mad rush to get that done
um so we're not done but yeah sleep and
time with family i need to remember what
my sons and my wife what's like hanging
out with us
so to summarize we are just um
you just have to like you just have to
count the ones that come true
that's the only one that we are waiting
for the mail is done
the deadline was yesterday so let me
just try to quickly summarize one more
time
we still have cures because that
deadline is not until
tomorrow at 5 pm so if anybody calls in
to cure and they provide the information
that's necessary those need to be
counted
i believe we're at the tail end of our
id required and those could be
provisional or they could be
the mail ballot because i have described
that that's a manual process but they
will be small numbers as you can see by
the day it's 549 that it's going up
the big number that's still left to
report are the provisionals and we don't
have any reason to believe that we won't
be rolling those into the results for
review
sometime tomorrow
you mentioned the recount if there is
going to be a recount do you guys feel
that you're prepared to
take that on you have enough staff to do
that absolutely
yeah we've been on track here it's been
worse than the recount we've we've been
on
track with everything as i started from
the beginning saying we will finish on
time
so yes we'll be ready to do whatever
comes our way
thanks folks have a great day we'll see
you tomorrow morning